[Musique]
400 ans d'histoire ininterrompues pour
fêter cet anniversaire le château de
Versailles a conçu un espace tout aussi
exceptionnel dans une enfilade de on
salles un temps habité par les grandes
têtes de la cour l'histoire se déroule
sous nos pieds cette galerie va laisser
entendre au visiteurs que ce qui va voir
est extrêmement compliqué qu'il n'y a
pas simplement une et une époque un état
du château de Versailles qui en a eu
1000 que tout ça a été le fruit de
transformation et d'événements très
complexes et que le résultat est
simplement sublime des années d'histoire
et de grands événements que nous refonds
vive la centaine d'oeuvres pour
certaines exposées pour la première fois
du règne de Louis XII des 1610 à
Louis-Philippe dernier roi de France la
première salle montre des grands
portraits magnifiques des souverains de
Versailles a commencé par Louis XII qui
a construit ce petit relais de chasse
que Louis XIV son fils aimait beaucoup
il a bien bien aimé cette atmosphère
dans ce lieu un peu abandonné marécageux
et petit à petit l'idée d'en faire un
très beau palais pas encore un palais du
gouvernement le siège de l'État ça ça
lui vient dans un deuxième temps et on
sait que c'est en 1682 qui décide
d'installer la cour à Versailles pour
des raisons aussi stratégiques
s'éloigner un peu de Paris et puis le
Louis XV bien sûr va lui succéder son
arrière petit-fils qui règne 50 ans
aussi qui va pas beaucoup changer
l'architecture mais énormément
l'intérieur du du château et puis
construire quand même quelques nouveaux
éléments importants mais en 1789
l'histoire du château et bouleversée le
5 octobre sous Louis XVI les
révolutionnaires envahissent le château
et saccage les lieux le destin du
château après la Révolution continue à
être non seulement riche passionnant
mais presque aussi vivant on a
l'impression que ce château est devenu
un organisme vivant d'accord le la
monarchie a disparu en France mais le
château de Versailles existe toujours en
1830 sous le Wii Philippe Versailles
devient un musée le lieu se transforme
une nouvelle fois et car Versailles ne
cesse jamais d'évoluer le château à
repensé l'exposition de manière
immersive avec des vidéos et des
reconstitutions 3D donc ce sont de très
belles vidéos des montages de de
fragments de films de de d'image
anciennes l'idée vraiment d'accompagner
puisque évidemment quand on parle par
exemple de du grand chantier de
restauration du château à la fin du 19e
siècle on a des images merveilleuses
tout ça vous montre le de toutes ces
strates de travaux d'efforts permanents
pour pour sauver le château et donc il
n'y a que le multimédia qui permet
d'évoquer tout ça une chose est sûre
même 400 ans après Versailles n'a pas
fini de nous révéler tous ses secrets
[Musique]